and you'll seeing that I'm going to zoom
in on these I got very excited so this
is the next slot coming through do yall
remember when these parasite cleanses
were huge on Tik Tok and everyone was
talking about well this is apparently a
parasite cleanse and they're getting a
colonic afterwards and I can't imagine
it's just ew oh my God you guys I've
been doing the cleanse it's day four of
the cleanse in a world first a
neurosurgeon in Australia has removed a
worm found alive in a woman's brain say
about 30 40% of the world is infected
with
toxoplasmosis ah yes parasites tape Wars
ring Wars hook Wars and more if you grew
up in America these nasty little suckers
probably never cross your mind most
Americans assume parasites only exist in
poor foreign countries don't drink the
water in Mexico you could get a parasite
don't eat the street food in China you
could get a parasite travel can be so
exciting new places to see and new foods
to eat but that can lead to to a
downside traveler's diarrhea can ruin
your trip and yet all the Americans we
just showed you the people in the videos
who took a parasite cleanse and got some
interesting results they weren't
traveling to foreign countries all the
time they weren't eating questionable
street meat and drinking dirty water
they were all just living a normal life
in America for years and yet they still
have parasites and you watching this
video right now you might have parasites
in you without even knowing because the
reality is one in five Americans have a
parasite in them right now that's right
one out of five of you watching this
right now might have a par in you all it
takes is drinking a little bit of dirty
water once eating day osimi kissing the
wrong person eating too many clams where
are people picking up these parasites
most commonly at the airport through
their friends sharing food with people
kissing people Barefoot on the earth
which is crazy because I'm a barefoot
guy right you know sitting on a bathroom
stall and on the toilet and boom your
body becomes This Guy's new home but
don't worry too much because parasites
won't send you to the hospital right
away but eventually they do grow and
take up more space which means over time
they can bury themselves deep within
your body they hang out in your gut and
Rob you of nutrients hookworms latch
onto the insides of your intestines and
suck out the blood which can lead to
anemia slower cognitive growth and
malnutrition they can even change the
way you think it's only recently that
people have sort of started wondering
about the effects that it can have on
adult people there's kind of increasing
awareness that it may lead to certain
mental health conditions it can
infiltrate our brains and form these
tissue cysts up there and and some
scientists think that it may lead to um
psychological problems as diverse as you
know rage disorders to uh schizophrenia
so if you feel constantly tired if you
have weird symptoms like itchy elbows
fatigue or extreme sugar Cravings if you
have depression anxiety or the slew of
other things that we just accept as
common place today and if it seems you
try like everything and nothing seems to
cure these issues and then you go to the
doctor and they just tell you it's
genetic or that you have autoimmune
disease and they just tell you to shove
a bunch of big farmer drugs down your
throat well the reality is you might
just have parasites in you but the good
news is that all the people you saw
earlier once they did a parasite cleanse
everything changed this is a Jar full of
whipworms I found them this is from just
one session of the toilet I'm not going
into details but that's them I found out
they also cause anemia I used it on my
last seasonal cleanse and the things
that came out of my body I know this is
gross but I have to say it I had like
slimy mucus and worms in my poop what's
sad is that Americans used to be a lot
more resistant to parasites back in the
days when our food wasn't depleted of
nutrients and we weren't spending 10
hours a day in a box under fluorescent
lights our immune systems could
naturally fight the parasites off but
now millions of Americans are becoming
infested with these organisms and
they're making us sicker and sicker by
the day I've been pooping out parasites
I have seen them in the toilet bowl you
guys remember that Lobster I ate about a
week ago well it had a parasite in it
and I'm pretty sure I'm infected ever
since I ate it I've been going to the
bathroom non-stop my diarrhea is
Unstoppable told a few friends and
they're like are you sure it was a
parasite to give you a measurement it
was about this long from this finger to
this finger that's how long it was
looked like a tapeworm a tiny brain
eating parasite has already claimed the
life of a boy following exposure to the
amoeba it enters the body through the
nose and can cause inflammation seizures
coma potentially
death and in this video we are going to
expose it
[Music]
all
it's time to unveil what Dr Oz calls the
mother of all parasites this nickname
picking it up is wormzilla
no is this what they call a tapeworm
this is a tapeworm and these tapeworm
can grow up to 30 ft it's not alive
right it's dead no it's dead parasites
are literally everywhere they're in your
tap water your unwashed produce they're
even in the tiny particles you inhale
when you change your cat's litter so
there's a few ways you can get it I
mentioned um you know changing cat
litter gardening if you don't uh really
thoroughly scrub vegetables there's
still dirt particles on it you can get
it that way and these parasites are
wrecking havoc on our bodies but back in
the early 1900s they weren't even close
to such a big deal Farmers breathed in
parasites all day while they wor in
Barns or Fields but these farmers were
also eating a diet that was super rich
in vitamins and minerals they were
eating food grown in Mineral rich soil
that was carefully tilled on small scale
farms and because of their mineral Rich
diet their immune systems were super
powerful the parasites they breathed
into the air or from eating slightly
spoiled meat wasn't a big deal because
their stomach acid and immune system was
strong enough to deal with them so
people and parasites have lived side by
side for hundreds of thousands of years
without any major issues but then the
Industrial Revolution spread across the
world and everything changed now it
wasn't about growing quality food and
mineral rich soil it was more about how
much food can we grow in the least
amount of time and for the least amount
of money possible before farmers were
forced to go slowly with their farming
because they didn't have any other
choice all they have was a measly old
rake and Pitchfork but with the
introduction of Machinery automatic
tractors mowers and yes automatic
pesticide sprayers farmers can now plant
way more across while saving both time
and money instead of using organic were
Rich fertilizers like manure which took
way longer to produce commercial Farmers
started using new improved synthetic
fertilizers made from fossil fuels and
instead of taking their time and
rotating crops to increase mineral
levels in the soil Farmers would plant
their crops Harvest them and then
replant on the same rundown soil until
the soil was completely devolved of any
nutrients like it is today and it didn't
take long for all this empty food to
start affecting People's Health as the
decades passed on Americans became more
and more susceptible to parasite
infections their stomach acid got weaker
their immune systems got weaker their
overall health got worse and suddenly
the parasites started to win suddenly
people were getting skin problems like
psoriasis something that was not common
before while chronic stomach issues and
bloating became a thing for the first
time my friend Noah Ryan who's dedicated
his life to finding out what actually
works when it comes to health and
vitality was experiencing a lot of these
symptoms when he found out that he had
parasites in his system parasites are
those microbes or organisms that do not
provide value to us and strictly Leech
from us right and my personal experience
uh
like most people you know or really
anybody for that matter that's ever
traveled eaten raw fish or anything I've
been exposed to a lot of parasites and
you know because of gut issues that I've
had and just because of you know the
natural state of our digestive systems
you know some of those parasites do
result in an infection but I was
actually going to school in Thailand and
I ate undercooked pork and I was the
sickest that I've ever been I had a
horrible fever I had the worst chills
and convulsions I was in bed for 2 days
and I was absolutely miserable and once
that acute infection went away I thought
I was good but I was not the same you
know I was there for another 6 months
and you know I had horrible digestive
issues I just had really bad stomach
pains and it was diagnosed as as IB
IBD uh ear B disorder and it wasn't
until you know I really started digging
into it I'm like there's something I
need to do for this and I tried taking
antibiotics and they didn't work I tried
doing a lot of things that you know
doctors were prescribing me and it
didn't work and it was until I went down
the parasite rabbit hole I realized that
I had osis which is a very common
microscopic uh parasite that's found
pretty abundantly in pork in particular
we link to Noah's Twitter below he's one
of the guys that I really trust for
health related stuff and aside from the
immediate symptoms like fever chills
convulsions the long-term effects on
Noah psyche thanks to his parasite
infection were what really hurted
[Music]
him
there is a class of organisms called
parasitic manipulators they were once
thought to be very rare but now experts
in the field think they're much much
more common than realized and these
organisms typically invade an animal and
they can do all kinds of things for
example they can Tinker with the neuros
circuits of their host sometimes they
change the hormone levels or levels of
neurochemicals they've got a whole bunch
of different tactics that allow them to
basically make the host behave the way
they wanted to a parasite's number one
goal is to multiply they want to mate
with other parasites lay eggs and slowly
take over whatever host they're living
in and because of this instinct to
reproduce when you have parasites in
your body they can drive you to do
things that are a little bit out of
character when mice are infected with
Toxoplasma gandii a parasite only found
in cats the parasites actually make the
mice sexually attracted to cat urine
which causes the mouse to not run when a
cat approaches know surfing the internet
looking for interesting topics to write
about I came across an article about a
parasite a one- cell protozoan that
invades the brain of rats and it turns
its innate fear of cats into an
attraction and when I say attraction I
mean sexual attraction the rodents
become sexually aroused by the scent of
C urine that's a very bad thing for a
mouse to be yes and what I learned is
needless to say that the rat soon ends
up in the belly of a cat which of course
is very convenient for the cat and
here's the thing right now 30% of the
human population has this exact same
parasite in them and some scientists
think that this parasite makes humans
more sexually promiscuous too and when I
continued reading I learned that about
30% of people around the world have this
parasite in their brains the vast
majority of them completely ignorant of
the fact and that some scientists were
concerned that it might actually be
altering our Behavior too and it's not
just mice getting hooked on cat urine
there are dozens of terrifying examples
of animals getting infected by a
parasite only to start behaving in a
really weird unnatural way you see a
spider on the the left hand side of the
screen I don't know if you can see it
but there is a tiny little white glob on
one side of the spider and that is the
egg of a PA AIC wasp the WASP attached
it there and as the egg develops into a
little larvae it produces a lot of
chemicals and these chemicals tell the
spider to build the Wasps a basically a
custom design nursery so the spider
abandons its normal weaving style and in
this case you can see that the the
normal weaving style is in the center
and to the far right you can see a
pretty crazy looking web here are some
of the drastic changes no one noticed
and I think the worst thing is The
Chronic uneasiness that I had when
dealing with that infection in terms of
you know like my mental health I just
had horrible brain fog I couldn't focus
for the life of me I was chronically
like underlyingly anxious which I
normally am not and you just feel
miserable and you know a lot of that is
your body actively trying to fight these
organisms and actively being in a state
of toxicity okay and are one of the
symptoms like depression or anxiety or
stuff like that absolutely right I mean
if you look at a lot of these diagnoses
they call it you know clinical
depressive major depressive disorder you
know generalized anxiety disorder all is
are are just you know disorders right
and any disorder it's not a true
diagnosis it's just a bundle of symptoms
so you know the mental aspect is is
pretty significant and we know that a
lot of parasites can you know
hypothetically infect the brain and it's
not like these symptoms are super rare
or only happen in extreme cases The
Stereotype of the ignorant slow talking
CER was actually thought to be due to a
widespread hookworm infection the lazy
mouth breathing Southerner came from
massive amounts of people that were
infected with parasites and these
parasites were extremely common
particularly when people walk around
Barefoot and they would get these worms
these worms would get into their system
and one of the side effects of these
worms was a decreased brain function
which leaves us with a lot of important
questions do suers talk the way they do
because a parasite infected their
Community are cat ladies crazy because
they're breathing in parasites all day
and is our society decaying because we
have parasites in US that are telling us
to overeat procrastinate and be sexually
promiscuous as crazy as it sounds
paraset could play a role in at least
part of these things a normal Mouse for
example with a normal gut microbiota
eager learner very curious if you put a
napkin ring in its cage it will Circle
it and sniff it with great interest the
same strain of Mouse without the normal
gut microbiota is not very curious it's
a slow learner it doesn't remember where
it's been and it doesn't
avoid wide open spaces and brightly lit
areas which would scream danger to a
normal Mouse all the like speets and and
a lot of these bacterias and infections
and viruses they they they get into the
brain they get into the spinal cord like
lime gets into the brain pretty quick
gets into this they they like those
areas because there's a lot of nerve
tissue once parasites get into your
central nervous system they can hideout
in cysts and infect you for life we took
him home on Wednesday and he died on a
seatter day a worm was removed from a
woman's brain imagine a worm swimming
inside your
[Music]
eye these things are pooping in our body
as well so it's like it's massive
massive heavy loads in the body which
then go to all the co-infection right so
all the co infections start to ignite
and then now we're talking about we're
getting all these symptoms and what is
mainstream calling it they're calling it
you know chronic fatigue syndrome
they're calling it you know fibromyalgia
they're calling it autoimmune conditions
when the whole time it's just a massive
burden of all of these different things
in the body that are taking us away from
our Optimal Health our immune system is
essentially getting stretched chances
are if you're an American watching this
video you know at least one person would
an autoimmune disease like psoriasis or
pilc disease where they can't eat bread
or a thyroid disease that makes them
tired all the time maybe you yourself
have one of these problems in these days
if you go to the doctor and you complain
that you can't digest bread anymore or
you have rashes all over your body
they'll usually tell you it's autoimmune
disease an autoimmune disease is when
your own immune system that has been
literally working fine for decades
suddenly decides out of nowhere to just
turn against you a doctor may even
explain it like a switch flipped in your
body and there's nothing you can do
about it they'll say it's probably
genetic maybe someone in your family l
10 Generations ago had a fxy gene and
now you'll just have to deal with it at
this point the doctor will give you a
prescription for some super expensive
drugs that will probably do more damage
in the long run and that's it but just
like parasite infections autoimmune
diseases are super new they actually
only became a thing in the mid 20th
century but once they arve they quickly
spread since the 1950s autoimmune
diseases have been skyrocketing marot a
busy personal trainer started to lose
hair gain weight and her get up and go
got up and went she suspected something
was wrong my metabolism had already
crashed at that point Talia says medical
test revealed she suffered from
Hashimoto an autoimmune disease that
attacks her thyroid it's it's
challenging it's hard Hashimoto is just
one of more than 80 different kinds of
autoimmune disorders like lupus
rheumatoid arthritis Ms and celiac
disease all are more common in women
statistics show not only are the
diseases frequent in our society they're
increasing and that's the part that's
that's very concerning uh we don't know
exactly why that's occurring why the
sudden jump well let's think about it
for a second nutrient boid food from our
mineral deficient soil working inside
all day under fluorescent lights instead
of working outside in the sun pesticides
in our food and water supply all leading
to a weakened immune system which leads
the parasites running rampant in our
bodies scientists are starting to
realize that the reason for these
autoimmune diseases isn't that your
immune system has randomly decided to
hait you out of then air it's because of
viruses bacteria and parasites studies
are coming out showing that auto amune
disorders like Hashimoto IBS and
psoriasis can all be linked to a
parasite infection so what is the
solution if you have parasites in you
the answer is a parasite
[Music]
cleanse as gross as it is to think about
there is a legitimate possibility that
you have a parasite in you right now and
the only way to stop them from ruining
your life is to get rid of them with a
parasite cleanse but there are a ton of
these parasite cleanses on the market
paragard is a popular one right now but
according to Noah you don't want to just
go in and kill all the parasites in your
system all at once why because parasites
can hold up to 10 times their own body
weight in toxins like heavy metals so if
you anal all your parasites at once
those toxins will get released into your
bloodstream and might literally even
make you more sick than you already are
that's why it's important to follow a
very specific regimen how do you cleanse
yourself of
parasites yeah so as I mentioned we have
these natural mechanisms the first step
is re fortifying those because you're
not like it's almost impossible to not
be exposed to some form of parasitic
organism you know all the time your goal
should be to make yourself as resilient
as possible so making sure that your
digestion is optimized that you're not
actively detracting from those natural
mechanisms uh by you know eating food
that damages your gut by consuming a lot
of pesticides right food Britten with
pesticides by not consuming some of
these fortified foods that have these
you know non-bioavailable forms of
minerals like iron or even folic acid
that are going to further contribute to
pathogenic growth and I think most
importantly optimizing for Baseline
nutrition to make sure that those
natural mechanisms have the building
blocks they need to function properly I
am particularly big on lowering lowering
stress and we think about stress as like
work stress right as psychological
stress but when I say stress I just mean
any detractors to our health uh
electromagnetic frequencies are
something that I personally look at I
definitely notice a difference because I
live in somewhere that has very low EMF
it's a very low EMF environment they
don't have they have 3G you know not
even 4G LTE or 5G and you know I'm not
just surrounded by Wi-Fi routers so I
think that's a factor as well um just
because of the lowlevel inflammation
that it causes at a systemic level every
single day okay makes sense um I I've
heard of parasite cleanses do those work
and how how do you do them yeah I I
think parasite cleanses are effective um
and it's often times a multi-step thing
it's not just like take one pill and
you'll be cured it is a gradual process
of slowly making your internal
environment less and less habitable or
habitable to these parasites there's a
lot of good brands out there that make
some more advanced products there's a
lot of natural compounds as well but you
know the interesting to me is that a lot
of these very ancient uh tribal rituals
if what if that's what you want to call
them like uh plant medicines like iasa
those were naturally and initially used
as purging agents right for for that
purpose right that's why they make you
throw up that's why they make you kind
of just flush everything so I think
there's a lot of natural things that you
can use um on like a gradual basis but
you know one of the best selling
pharmaceutical drugs out there is icon
and you know they want to paint it as a
horer wormer and something that is not
uh suitable for human consumption and
you know hopefully I don't get in
trouble for this but I'm just St the
fact that it has been used for so long
in in human use cases and saved
countless lives because it its efficacy
as a as as an antiparasitic now uh in
some places you can get iin over the
counter where I live I can just get iin
over the counter so you know typically
like in common practice throughout a lot
of cultures you know having a biannual
parasite cleans is quite effective and I
personally go that route and then
sometimes I'll include some
other uh like par anti-parasitic
compound herbs like herbal compounds and
there's so many uh you know black
walnuts a big one oregano oil is one of
my personal favorites I just think that
if you really think you're dealing with
a parasitic infection you should do the
research and and do it right and really
kind of understand it from top to bottom
now the issue with killing off any
pathogenic organism is that they have a
toxin load right as I mentioned
parasites hold you know up to 10 times
their body weight in heavy metals so you
kill off that parasite you're going to
be releasing a lot of those toxins back
into your or system or say you dislodge
a parasite from its tissue it has the
opportunity to go and Rel Lodge into a
different tissue so it's important to
whenever you're doing any form of this
make sure that your primary step State
one and state two detox functions are
operating properly right like your liver
is that primary detox organ making sure
that your liver is you know in tiptop
shape so obviously avoiding detractors
right what are those detractors going to
be alcohol that's going to be having the
suboptimal nutrition in general I
personally take liver boosting herbs
like TKA which is one of my personal
favorites so that's that's step number
one and then step number two is using
binding agents so these agents that
essentially have the capability to
absorb some of these toxins they have
like really high surface area things
like zeolite panite clay activated
charcoal which is my personal favorite
and that's going to bind up some of you
know these endotoxins and help you
safely excrete those okay for the more
natural stuff like oregano oil what does
that process look like yeah I mean
fasting is something that people try to
use right because as I mentioned you
know parasites feed off the same things
that you feed off of so a lot of people
will do prolonged fast they will
essentially slowly make their
environment less inhabitable for these
parasites oregano oil is more of a slow
tapering off black walnut it's kind of
the same thing there's a number of other
ones as well but those are the primary
ones that I've personally used and you
know these aren't without their risk
factors right like these are powerful
natural herbs so you have phase one
which is to support your digestion and
liver function with a healthy diet full
of organic pesi free foods that are
hopefully grown in Mineral rich soil
then we have phase two killing the
parasites using something like itin or
natural herbs the natural herbs will
take a lot longer though and then phase
three which is taking a binding agent
like activated charcoal to absorb the
heavy Ms that will be released another
thing Noah really recommends you avoid
which I never thought of is iron
fortified Foods because parasites love
to fuel themselves on metals like iron
so if you needed yet another reason to
cut out American fortified wheat and
flour this is it and while you're doing
a parasite cleanse he also recommends
taking something like colostrum to
support your microbiome and digestion
during the process well colostrum is
primary mechanism is being incredible
for fortifying your gut health right so
rebalancing your gut and subsequently
your digestive system so a lot of it is
that preventative mechanism it's going
to make you more resilient and colostrum
really is is in my opinion one of the
closer things I've seen to a Panacea for
its abilities to induce igf-1 insulin
like growth factor so it's incredibly
anabolic um it's incredibly healing but
in terms of parasites in particular it
does seem to do a pretty beneficial job
at bolstering your immune system right
because what rum is is it's the first
milk that's released from a ruminant
animal like a goat or like a cow for
their child and the primary focus and
and reason that this milk is special is
because that is the milk that is going
to populate and fortify that new calf or
that new baby goat's immune system and
it has the same similar function with us
and humans so we've seen claustrum used
a lot for you know persistent viral
infections we've seen claustrum used a
lot for fungal infections bacterial
infections and parasitic infections also
fall in that bucket and if if you're
interested in colostrum the brand I
recommend is miracu no Noah is not
affiliated with miracu at all but I am
that the sponsor of this video what I
love about mirom is that there are no
natural flavors no sweeteners none of
the bad stuff it's literally just pure
grassfed colostrum powder along with
amolin which is a special type of
protein that increases how much of the
nutrients and cholesterol your body can
uptake making Miracle Moon more
effective than anything on the markets
all it takes is a scoop a day I've been
using it for a while now to improve my
gut microbiome and obviously to prevent
things like parasitic infections and it
works not only for me but for these
people too people report higher energy
better sleep their gut is less angry
their immune system is better they're
not as bloated anymore and much much
more and Miracle MO is giving you a
special 10% discount so you can try it
out for yourself just click the link
below to buy it on Amazon now so scroll
down click the link below to try Miracle
moon now and don't forget to follow Noah
on Twitter while you're at it stay
dangerous and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]